en périphérie des villes le
développement des quartiers comme ici à
cambuston sur la commune de saint-andré
conduit généralement à l'émergence de
groupes organisés dans le cas présent ce
sont les femmes du coin qui se sont
rassemblés à l'initiative de rose google
chine dans un atelier de couture
né d'un projet soutenu par la maison de
la famille cette initiative reflète le
besoin pour ces femmes de demeurer
active et créatrice c'est en quelque
sorte une passerelle pour susciter la
solidarité est refusée oisiveté qu'elle
nous rôle de la maison des familles de
la commune le rôle de la maison de la
famille dans la commune c'est un lieu
d'écouté d'accord et d'orientation pour
les familles comme son nom l'indiqué
maison de la famille c'est un lieu
d'écouté et pour orienter les gens
orienter les gens dans les différents
services c'est les gens qui viennent à
la maison de la famille c'est des gens
qui
on n'ose pas affronter directement les
services ou alors c'est le sait des gens
qui ne savent pas bien
s'orienter faire une demande de logement
aller vers un service social
c'est la maison de la famille sakhaline
quel que soit le problème oui tout à
fait même problème conjugal si on les
oriente vers
les différents services mais comme on
sait que la démarche pour être bénévole
à la maison de la famille
c'est quelqu'un visiblement la famille
qui m'avait contacté la corde m'a
demandé si je voulais pas venir dans
l'association des maisons de la famille
je le dis mais pourquoi pas donc ça
s'est fait comme ça et pour l'atelier de
cambuston où nous sommes c'est moi qui
ai eu l'idée
avec mon entourage avec toutes les
femmes mon entourage vu que ça faisait
longtemps que je voulais faire quelque
chose dans le quartier donc je voulais
faire un projet
faire un groupe des façons que tout le
monde profite et j'ai suggéré mon projet
à monsieur juppé le président de la
maison de la famille
et il m'a demandé de lui donner c'est un
nombre de personne pour pouvoir faire
monter un projet
vous avez le souci vous de créer un
pour que les femmes puissent venir
échanger leurs possibilités leur
capacité créé terrain mais comment ça
vous est venue cette idée
j'aime la couture et l'artisanat et mais
dans un esprit de collectivités oui
voyez donc
je ne me voyais pas à prendre ses
activités tout seul et pour pouvoir
avoir plus de connaissances
j'ai pensé peu un groupe serait été
mieux donc vu qu'il y avait celle de
main aussi dans mon entourage donc là
on s'est dit pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
monter quelque chose surtout qu'elle
n'avait pas combustion que tu il ya des
il ya eu les ateliers avec la rechute
d'inquiéter avec les intérieurs de la
fuite
et après contre salé c'était ça ça se
dissout mais moi je me suis dit si je
crée quelque chose il faut que ça aille
jusqu'au bout qu
ariane vaitilingom et la responsable de
la rechute qui a soutenu le projet de
cambuston en assurant avec son équipe
une assistance technique auprès du
groupe
quel est votre intervenez comment et à
quel moment vous faites en ce qui
concerne la maison de la famille à
saint-andré c'est elle ou le monde bien
précises il y avait des mères famille
qui fait chanter la maison de la famille
qui était adhérente à la maison de la
famille et qui a bien voulu
sortir un peu de chez elle se retrouver
bien si on peut discuter tout ça et là
le président de la maison de la famille
m'a contacté pour me demander si c'était
possible de dons cadre et un gros alors
moi je ne pouvais pas dire oui d'emblée
d'abord il fallait que jamais la balle
de mentalités aussi et ensuite il
fallait travailler sur un projet ce ne
peut pas travailler n'est pas de comment
on travaille sur un projet hélas la
personne concernée et le président de la
maison de la famille a mis sur pied un
projet est évidente ce prochain
justement belle 2d j'ai là c'était
vraiment la demande forte des d'un
groupe de personnes qui désiraient de se
retrouver de mettre en commun leur
savoir de partager et puis aussi
d'apprendre quelque chose se pose en
creux elle a un technicien de lens était
venu par exemple pour la peinture ce
tissu quoi l'artisanat pour les
transformations et tout ça
ces femmes qui viennent elles n'ont pas
forcément des connaissances techniques
comment ça se passe on a une formatrice
de la mjd hafid qui aimera mwaro que la
conseillère de la culture et de
l'artisanat est ce que vous avez et
aider financièrement
aidés financièrement par les familles
oui
c'est la maison la famille qui nous
donne tout le matériel les machines le
calme
c'est un atelier de couture et n'atteint
donc c'est eux qui nous donne le
matériel et
nous on emmène le tissu et réaliser
notre projet de l'atelier existe depuis
deux ans l'atelier existe depuis ie août
2000 oui c'est tout récent mais on a
déjà fait une exposition en avril 2010
position qui était basée sur la couture
se lance dans les travaux qu'on
mis en place avec le groupe
les divers travaux est-ce que
l'exposition a eu lieu dans le quartier
oui ça s'est fait dans la mairie annexe
de cambuston et c'était notre première
exposition très enrichissante et avec
les fonds on a pu racheter réinvestir
acheter des machines pour pouvoir
bénéficier le groupe
mais toute décision est pris avec le
groupe vous êtes un groupe de combien de
personnes actuellement
actuellement c'est un groupe
comment dire ça c'est un groupe fidèle
c1 deux femmes et deux femmes
uniquement c'est un groupe sidel depuis
qu'on a démarré
cet atelier
parce que c'est pas l'association c'est
l'atelier 2 cambuston qui est gérée par
l'association de la maison de la famille
on est
groupe de trente femmes mais c'est des
femmes qui viennent on la parle d'être
en même temps un des femmes qui viennent
temps en temps vu qu'ils ont des
occupations
personnelles aussi donc y viennent mais
notre effectif est de 30
voilà mais on est tous ceux des
meilleures familles donc on a choisi les
horaires ensemble c'était le mardi
après-midi jeudi après midi de 13h30 à
15h30 afin qu'on récupère nos enfants à
l'école on peut dire qu'il sait c'est
aussi un lieu de partage tout à fait
mais c'est un lieu de partage des côtes
des changes du fer et du savoir faire
c'est un lieu où on peut créer modifier
transformé
en fait pas que de la couture ce patron
et on fait beaucoup de choses et c'est
très enrichissant pour le groupe ce que
vous confectionnez ici ce sont des
travaux personnels ou ce sont des
travaux que vous pouvez vendre non ce
qu'on fait à l'atelier c'est du travail
personnel d'accord pour le moment 1 mais
quand une exposition tout le monde fait
l'exposition on se donne
deux à trois mois avant l'exposition
pour faire l'exposition mais autrement
c'est du travail personnel sur la
confectionner une robe si on veut fait
n'importe quoi la peinture qu'on fait
dans notre atelier la pêche sont issus
la broderie mais à la machine avec les
intervenants de la fuite
qui viennent
d'une fois tous les deux mois tous les
trois mois mais il ya des intervenants
donc on peut faire ce qu'on veut quand
les intervenants mais la peinture ce
tissu ont fait un âne au pochoir on a
notre peinture
si on veut faire quelque chose on peut
le faire chez nous d'accord voilà c'est
pas
c'est pas et les cours sont gratuits
ça il faut bien savoir que les cours
sont gratuits
est ce que vous trouvez que les femmes
ont bien répondu à l'appel à tout à fait
mais dès que je leur ai demandé il monde
il n'y a pas de problème c'est une bonne
chose y en a pas dans le coin donc il
faut le faire c'est un lieu de des
changes et sur les quais ski qu'est-ce
que vous souhaiter pour une meilleure
évolution de l'atelier nous ce qu'on
souhaite d'avoir un local plus grand
bien sûr
est de pouvoir faire autre chose que la
couture
vous avez beaucoup de temps dit prends
pas beaucoup mais on essaye de se
consacrer deux fois par semaine
le mardi après-midi et le jeudi après
midi du temps libre on n'a pas beaucoup
vu qu'on a plus ou moins une activité
professionnelle
donc on est obligé de se consacrer à la
maison à l'attractivité
et
à essayer de gérer nos jouets mais quoi
qu'est ce que vous attendez de dire aux
femmes qui habitent le quartier même de
venir nous rencontrer et devenir plus
nombreux et donc elles peuvent venir
sans qu'ils aient une connaissance
forcément à la pratique je veux dire de
l ont pas besoin de connaître de contre
non non on est apte à apprendre toute
personne même ceux qui savent comme ceux
qui ne savent pas
si elles veulent elles peuvent apprendre
à coudre c'est un atelier ou
où on peut accueillir toutes catégories
de personnes déjà qu'est ce qui vous
motive
parce que j'aime ça j'aime le contact
était valable ouais j'aime le contact
j'aime aider les gens
j'aime faire partager est-ce que vous
avez rencontré des obstacles pour créer
cet atelier non heureusement s'est fait
tout seul et bien
non on a eu de la chance en quelque
sorte ça c'est ça suivi son cours normal
le projet la signature l'atelier le
local ça s'est bien passé et je je je
suis très contente même les gens ils
sont fidèles à ce jeu j'apprécie pour
monter quelque chose ils sont toujours
là j'apprécie bien le groupe